megan is with us in ohio hi Megan
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show so my
husband and I are different and we have
a four pointed pissant emergency fund
they just put in a cash offer that was
accepted on our first what would be our
first home and it's a HUD foreclosure um
which we're learning more and more about
the problem and our hesitation with it
is that pretty much the entire offer if
we go through with this it's like all
the money that we have aside from our
emergency fund and it's in a great
location when the girl of it it's not
close to my family because my husband's
job but they're quite a bit of work when
we clean out our mostly cosmetic as far
as we know right now
it might be some bigger things like
there's a fourth heat which we don't
like um no NEC owners around cooler back
because we have a little daughter which
we're not crazy now so it things like
that that we really have to take our
time to take out the cash to fix in the
future but you hear yourself probably
being there for a number of years so and
Q what's really appealing about it is a
lot of the home area I was a hundred
thousand dollars you want and what we'd
be paying for this house so it's in a
really really great location we don't
know what to do and you talk to the
beginning of the show I don't know
wanted what to do why did you buy it
why'd you put an offer on it
location is really great
but if you already made all your
decisions you bought that house yeah I
guess we can't go back out you know kind
of an selection yeah no but why did you
go this far if you were this unsure I
guess you weren't in the beginning we've
been looking at so many houses and well
I mean I'm worried about the in-ground
pool I'm worried about the baseboard
heating I'm worried about the work that
has to be done it's all of our money
where were all these decisions those
were all things that were obvious before
you buy
yeah yeah they were doing you're
absolutely right yeah and that's my
hesitation like that and that's that's
why I'm a little scared so I guess so it
was just something like your husband
decided to do and you were like half
going along with no no no no we were
both in it and I think we both kind of
it a housekeeper in the beginning of it
for sure and you know what would you be
paying for the house one hundred forty
eight thousand one hundred and forty
eight and you think homes in the area
are worth 250 mm-hmm what will it take
to repair this house I would say at
least ten thousand I would say more yeah
I think so yeah you got to put heating
and air in a house mm-hmm heating their
system alone is probably gonna you know
touch up I mean you got ductwork and
everything because you're a baseboard
heat right yeah it's not easy to we got
cosmetic is the roof good I think so
yeah hmm yeah we haven't had the whole
plant cash for the house yeah we want
your household income I sixty-five
sixty-five thousand where did you get a
hundred and forty eight thousand dollars
this say it's like crazy over the past
couple years um and just found ourselves
what's your husband do for a living a
technical product manager and do these
repairs well my father is a contractor
and a carpenter so he would help we do
some ourselves to hire people as well
what are you living in now an important
it's a month-to-month apartment so you
can stay there a little while while you
get some of these repairs done um it's
livable right now so we could move into
it I'm I'm sorry
we know much harder to do repairs around
you yes yeah for sure yeah
yeah and it wouldn't be a little be
paying rent on this apartment while we
you know on the house I'm working on
that how old are you - 32 I'm 32 he's 34
I can't tell whether you've gotten cold
feet or whether you don't know how to
make decisions I can't tell what's going
on I really can't tell because you
bought a house you bought a house you
made the decision to spend the money
that you have that you've the precious
money that you've saved up down to the
last dollar which means you have to cash
flow out of your budget the money for
the repairs and now you're freaking out
and I can't tell what's causing that you
you you really should be like embracing
the adventure and excited or you should
have not entered into this deal in the
first place one of the two but this kind
of half in half out thing I can't figure
out so I don't really know what to tell
you I would tell you that repairs costs
more than you think they're going to
they take longer than you think they're
going to and doing repairs while you
live in a home is known as hell doing a
remodel while you live there causes
sawdust to be in your soup and it just
takes the fun out of everything
everything smells like dirt while you're
living there and drywall dust and paint
fumes and the normal things that go with
remodeling a house I don't mind a
remodeling a house but remodeling a
house while you live in it is a complete
pain in the butt so you know I think you
guys need to sit back and decide are we
gonna walk away from this and be happy
about walking away from it or are we
gonna embrace this and be happy about
embracing it and I'm okay either way I
didn't hear anything here that scares me
that bad except that you're scared
that's what's weird